jours à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france quel regard
portez vous sur ces manifestations qui
agitent la colombie depuis maintenant un
mois
ce que j'observe c'est que une partie
des colombiens pour pas dire la majorité
des colombiens sont aujourd'hui opposés
au système de réforme fiscale qui a été
retiré et plus largement est opposée au
gouvernement à ce qu'il représente a
river qui est l'ancien président et qui
manoeuvre derrière ivan touquet ils sont
opposés à un système politique dans son
ensemble et ça ils le disent depuis
depuis un mois est ce que j'observe avec
cette nouvelle provocation qu'il a eu à
en envoyant les 7000 militaires à cali
c'est que là le gouvernement ne cherche
pas une solution et cherche de la
violence nous avons des manifestants qui
sont très pacifique
je tiens à rappeler que celle sur des
manifestations pacifiques et ceux qui
veulent de la violence ceux qui veulent
qu on aille sur une impasse politique
c'est actuellement le gouvernement sinon
on n'aurait pas depuis un mois de telles
violences
et on serait pas dans cette situation
qui est une véritable la passe donc pour
sortir de cette situation
ce qu'il faudrait ce serait que ivan doc
et où enfin à bord le gouvernement ou
même les certains son entourage aille
vers les manifestants propre fasse des
propositions
ou pourquoi pas aille vers le la mise en
place de certaines mesures sociales qui
sont demandés par par les manifestants
est aujourd'hui c'est malheureusement
pas le cas 49 morts c'est le bilan
depuis le début de cette contestation en
un mois à ce qu'ils aient eu un
précédent d'une crise politique aussi
grave dans l'histoire récente
colombienne
est ce qu'au fond on entend des gens lui
en quelle fauqué vous m'entendez 49
morts je le disais c'est le bilan en un
mois ce qui a eu un précédent d'une
crise politique aussi grave dans
l'histoire récente de la colombie on a
un petit problème technique entend pas
alors oui alors là je vous attends
c'était par rapport aux six mois
précédents
oui voilà c'est ça alors oui on prend
les petits geeks alors est ce qu'il ya
des précédents effectivement il faut
comprendre que ces manifestations qui
ont lieu depuis un mois sur la poursuite
du mouvement social qui a eu fin 2019
début 2001 et qui a dû s'arrêter pour
cause de coheed puisqu'aujourd'hui la
situation en colombie
plus que simplement cette réforme
fiscale c'est un mal être qui est
profond et qui existent dans la société
et pour lesquels à la fois par les
résultats électoraux et par plusieurs
mouvement social on voit qu'ils aiment
la contestation voit que le modèle
colombien ne satisfait plus l'ensemble
de la population la majorité de la
population et principalement les jeunes
le effectivement il ya un précédent qui
sont les manifestations 2019
c'est pour ça que ces manifestations et
c'est quelque chose que par exemple j'ai
un peu vu sur votre sujet mais j'ai pu
aussi eu - voire dans d'autres journaux
on doit les prendre dans un ensemble
c'est pas juste une exception il ya eu
un phénomène de violence qui a duré un
mois à cette période de deux 2 mai 2021
danse etc
c'est un système d'ensemble c'est
quelque chose qu'on aborde de manière
beaucoup plus structurelle c'est que
c'est un mal être existe au sein de la
société et pour beaucoup de colombiens
et colombiennes
mais de ça depuis depuis malheureux
depuis malheureusement des années alors
vous disais tout à l'heure que le
gouvernement doit tendre la main
justement aux manifestants mais est ce
que cette main tendue
elle va trouver une issue parce qu'on a
le sentiment que c'est un bras de fer
finalement qui est sans issue puisque
les manifestants demandent aussi un
manifeste contre l'actuel président ivan
doc est oui alors ils m'ont main je
considère que un homme politique est
responsable aujourd'hui d'une centaine
de mort de centaines de disparus
et depuis 2000 blessés c'est un homme
politique qui a failli et qui doit
démissionner donc aujourd hui la
revendication qui est légitime du de la
démission d'yves un dock et une rotation
qui comme je dis qu'il est tout ce qui
est plus victime après deux propositions
peuvent effectivement mis en place si on
fait une sorte de compromis
par exemple les manifestants réclament
beaucoup la question de l'emploi ou la
question des aides sociales qui sont qui
qu'ils soient augmentés notamment il
parlera du revenu de base
même si c'est pas exactement la même
chose que le l'europe du bascon qu'on
connaît en france il ya beaucoup de
menaces qui sont faits par l'actuel
gouvernement event ok sur des projets de
réformes qui veulent relancer notamment
sur la question de la santé sur la
question de des retraites sur la
question du droit du travail c'est sûr
par exemple sur des sur ces questions-là
sursis
j'ai deux se situent à effectivement il
a pris pour l instant mais le problème
qui là est la raison pour laquelle il va
sur une escalade de la violence et qu'il
est arrivé vers une impasse politique
aujourd'hui puis pour lui renoncé et
proposer un pacte ou proposer quoi que
ce soit ce serait une défaite qui pour
lui serait oui que pour le camp uribiste
de manière générale pour la droite dure
colombienne ce serait une défaite sans
précédent et à leurs yeux
peut-être que d'ailleurs légitimement à
leurs yeux de lors de leur point de vue
de l'intérêt de l'oligarchie et qu'il
représente renoncé aujourd'hui c'est la
promesse de l'erdre c'est la propre
c'est la promesse de perdre demain
sans compter que vous avez l'année
prochaine les élections présidentielle
et les élections isie dati vous je
rappelle le candidat petro de gauche
radicale est très bien placé dans les
sondages
très rapidement je viens de caf on tire
à votre commentaire sur sur le décès
d'un enquêteur du parquet qui fait
partie des trois victimes
la nuit dernière lors des manifestations
qui a tiré sur la foule
il a tué un civil et il a été lynché par
les manifestants et le on voit que ce
qu'essaye de faire il va adopter en
allant sur l' escalade de la violence en
envoyant des en envoyant maintenant les
militaires les policiers en allant sur
cette logique là tous tous que ce sur
quoi ça peut mener c'est presque logique
de guerre civile et d'affrontement
permanents et donc de la violence
permanente ce que ne veulent pas les
manifestants effectivement c'est un
épisode dramatique des deux côtés
malheureusement mais il faut voir ça de
avec plus de hauteur et comprendre
aujourd'hui tu lui qui provoque ça c'est
ivan bouquet qui veut une impasse
politique encore novice il n'y avait pas
une impasse politique savait des
propositions savez un plan social c'est
un pacte social s'il y avait des signaux
comme la démission d'yves indiqué s'il y
avait des signaux pour l'opposition pour
les manifestants s'ils avaient la fin
des violences
on ne serait pas malheureusement
d'associations très triste où chaque
mort est effectivement une totale une
totale tragédie au combi et il y en a
chaque jour julian qu'il faut que je
rappelle que vous êtes secrétaire
national du parti de gauche spécialistes
amérique du sud